hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 5 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet here we go Jesus is back I'm so
happy he's one of my favorite characters
on The Walking Dead just because of the
way he's able to lighten the tone but
still be a badass like he has mad skills
but things have been so dire for the
last couple of episodes that you just
need somebody to lighten the tension so
Jesus
monster truck rallies to the rescue so
let's do top 10 WTF and comic book
Easter eggs they're a couple really big
comic book arcs that they're setting up
so I'll just try to deal with the stuff
that they did in this episode and if
they do end up doing stuff from later in
the comics we can talk about it in the
episodes where it happens but number 10
Maggie's still alive as expected this is
a comic book thing like she had some
trauma with her baby in the comics but
as she's fine in this episode same thing
happens in the comics the doctors like
you know maybe you had some trauma like
he has no idea what happened with Glenn
and Abraham but then number 9 Sasha
buried them out back and she takes
Glen's watch which is actually
Herschel's lays it down but everybody's
favorite douchebag walks in Gregory and
if you forgot about him from season 6
he's basically like the feckless leader
of hilltop complete pushover but as he
says during the episode oh I got him
right where I want him I'm totally
dealing with the situation but really
they're just trying to set up somebody
else taking over so they really wanted
you to hate him in this episode so
things are all proceeding according to
comic book plan he's mostly just worried
about what the Savior's are gonna do
when they find out that they helped them
but number 8 the Savior's roll out a big
show monster truck rally time it was so
hilarious when you know number 7 at the
end of the episode Maggie
explained where she learned that trick
oh there was this guy in high school and
I laughed so hard when Enid asked her if
it was the guy that she ran over like oh
you ran over the guy with your car no no
no I ran over his Camaro but don't you
just love Maggie that much more knowing
that she did that when she was in high
school like that's how badass she was
then number 7 I think what they're
implying is that Maggie will eventually
take leadership of hilltop but like when
Jesus was talking to them at the end of
the episode and said that he had
somebody else in mind
like you know when he first came in
Gregory was in charge and he couldn't
imagine anyone else taking the job so I
think what he was implying is is that
he's eventually going to ask Maggie to
step up just because she seems like such
a strong person
when Deanna was still alive they
actually for shouted a little bit of
this like she asked Maggie to work with
her kind of learned how to administrate
the group so Maggie's been learning to
be a leader for a while now so the arc
she's on is a little bit clearer like
she's this strong single mom who is now
going to be this very strong leader
eventually but number six Gregory is
going to be like the puppet leader for
the time being he's in charge
effectively but he's not in charge that
was what Jesus's whole speech was about
he was standing up to him look this is
the way it's gonna be
they're staying that's it but number
five back to the safe zone so actually I
felt like the carl storyline was a
little crazier just because of what it
was implying but number five rick and
michonne side trip Michonne seems like
she might run into the kingdom Rick they
tease might run into another group from
the comics but it's not the whispers
there's a lot of talk about the whispers
this past week but they weren't saying
they were coming on this season they
just said they would be coming on sooner
rather than later I think the big thing
though even though we're gonna see all
these different groups is that the
survivors themselves will remain split
up like even though they might see Carol
there that doesn't mean that Carol will
come back with them and it seems like
Maggie and Sasha are staying put at
Hilltop for now too so the group is more
fractured than ever but before I get to
the Carl stuff I'll say you know number
four is Simon in his performance with
Gregory he's the new negan you might
hear people call him Trevor just make
that joke because he's the same actor in
real life that does the character Trevor
in Grand Theft Auto so even though his
name is Simon on The Walking Dead like
when you hear people referring to him as
Trevor that's what they're talking about
but he just had that crazy performance
being the new negan of hilltop oh those
last people you dealt with they were
taking it kind of soft on you so he's
kind of trying to do his best negan
impersonation he's doing a pretty good
job of it too but the problem is is that
even though negan is every bit this
[ __ ] he is way more terrifying and he
has some of the muscle and the weaponry
to back it up like negan could axe
we throw down if he needed to but I
would be willing to bet that Sasha could
take Simon if she really wanted to but
she would have a much harder time if she
were to try to take negan on directly
which doesn't give you a lot of hope for
Carl's mission so number three Carl goes
after Enid on a Sunday Drive I just you
know felt like going for a drive you
could make the joke that he's a terrible
driver because he has no depth
perception but he probably would have
done that anyway but it's still pretty
funny just super casual just Ram in the
car around just destroying everything
but if you forgot about the big
reference they dropped to the previous
season so when he locked her in the
armory and she was like I didn't need to
see it that was when they went to take
Maggie to hilltop and she was talking
about having to watch Glenn and Abraham
die so she you know she tells Karl I'm
sorry you had to see it so it's not all
a huge bummer because they find that
pair of skates and have like a really
brief moment of just being kids before
Karl opens up and explains I'm gonna
kill negan you know number two Karl
plotline from the comics he plans to
kill negan in fact these mattresses that
he's hiding under are the mattresses
that the Savior's burned in that
previous episode that was what Michonne
was so pissed about you know crying at
the end of the episode that burning pile
of mattresses that the Savior's have
taken so slight change from the comics
but that's what you're looking at right
here so we can follow that along with
the episodes I'll talk about the comic
book stuff as we see it but he says the
exact same thing he undertakes the exact
same type of mission in the comics but
the difference is is that comic book
Karl is way smaller so it's even more of
a WTF and speaking of which know number
one just like that final end tag where
Jesus is jumping on the back of the
truck and sees Karl and just casually
gives them a what's up like it's no big
deal
that they're on the back of a truck
headed to hell so let me know what was
your favorite moment from the episode
there were a lot of nice tags like
Herschel's watch like that's a nice
object that's kind of followed the
characters around like Hershel gave it
to Glenn now Maggie gave it to eated
there's this whole theme about letting
go you know burning the bodies versus
burying them remembering things maggie
comes to the conclusion like the right
conclusion i think that she's able to
let this stuff go
and move forward because we have each
other Carl is the other side of that he
cannot let this go that is why he's on
this crackpot mission to go kill negan
but at least you have Jesus there I
think they did that in the episode just
so you wouldn't feel so bad for him like
if he gone by himself there's absolutely
no way this would have gone well but
with Jesus there he might be able to
help Carl out a little bit
so I think they wanted you to be a
little bit more hopeful especially you
know as you hear Sasha sharpening her
knife smoking Abraham's cigar they're
like that was just another great way to
let you know that the survivors people
like Sasha are just gonna be sitting
around letting the Savior's come take
half of their stuff every single week so
the hilltop stuff the Carl stuff right
out of the comics can't wait to see
where they go with it if there's any
other Easter eggs you guys spotted that
I didn't mention just let me know in the
comments below I really feel like maggie
is gonna benefit from this season of
Walking Dead the most she's gonna get
one of the best character arts as well
as Carl at least in comparison to his
arcs in previous seasons he's always
been something of a supporting character
but now I think they're really trying to
do something interesting he thinks to
the comics that's actually pretty easy
to do but I did just hear a really crazy
Chandler Riggs rumor so if you guys want
I'll do a video about that later this
week but it's just a rumor right now but
what's gonna happen next is I'll be
doing new Westworld in a new Walking
Dead trailer so be sure to subscribe to
get that stuff in there is a new Walking
Dead giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so those other
videos will start posting early tomorrow
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn about Emilio
Clark from Game of Thrones being in the
new Star Wars Han Solo movie and you can
click here for my Westworld video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight